les premiers travaux ont débuté en
juillet 2010 9 plusieurs parties du
technocentre renault de guyancourt vont
connaître une rénovation une
réorganisation des espaces de travail et
une amélioration des systèmes
énergétiques des infrastructures datant
de 1998
vous êtes ici donc sur la première zone
qui a été curé donc comme vous voyez on
enlève tout tout est trié par type de
produit pour être envoyés en recyclage
après donc nous avons complètement vidé
le plateau de tous ses équipements de
tous est fluide et tout va être remis à
neuf
ces équipements qui sont là ont
quasiment en 20 ans pour la plupart
indifférents les a changés mais sinon en
moyenne ils ont 20 ans donc là on remet
tout à neuf c'est un nouvel immeuble que
l'on train de construire on ne garde que
la peau extérieure
ces transformations c'est le programme
le tcr pour efficience du technocentre
renault du nouveau mobilier des espaces
de réunion du matériel neuf
des outils actuellement en test par des
collaborateurs engagés sur cette
question c'est un verrou à s'y dévouent
électriques pour que chacun puisse le
régler comme il veut et travailler
debout souvent en fin de journée on voit
que les gens se lèvent mettent leurs
bureaux de boue ils travaillent debout
ben au plus haut plus haut et tous les
postes sont équipés d'écrans avec des
bras multifonctions qui permettent de le
mettre dans tous les sens au coeur de
cette réflexion lancée en 2015 le
travail collaboratif à travers des
espaces de travail et de détente comme
ceux working qu'a fait ce qu'on veut
c'est effectivement donner un maximum de
confort pour tous qui est
l'environnement physique pour que le
salarié se met dans les meilleures
conditions pour travailler
l'objectif de cette opération c'est de
décloisonner et de d'améliorer la
convivialité et la collaboration entre
les personnes et les mettre plus dans la
lumière
la fin des travaux est prévue pour 2023
à noter aussi la construction d'odyssée
un nouveau bâtiment en bois installés
sur le site